at 1 45 in the morning yesterday u.s
marshals arrested a 26 year old man
outside of supreme court justice brett
kavanaugh's home the young man had
traveled across the country carrying a
gun
ammo pepper spray a knife a crowbar and
zip ties among other tools to help him
murder justice brett kavanaugh and very
possibly his wife and two daughters all
of whom were home at the time of the
incident according to reports the
would-be assassin was angry that the
court might overrule roe v wade which he
learned after a leftist leaked the
opinion
and so he set out to kavanaugh's home
address which he found on the internet
after a leftist group doxed the justice
really scary stuff for our system of
government but at least we can take some
comfort that even the democrats have
urged their supporters to leave the
justices and their families alone right
right oh no wait just kidding they've
been encouraging threats and illegal
demonstrations the whole time
these activists posted a map with the
home addresses of the supreme court
justices is that the kind of thing this
president wants to help your side make
their point look i think the president's
view is that there's a lot of passion a
lot of fear a lot of
sadness from many many people across
this country about what they saw in that
leaked document we obviously want
people's privacy to be respected we want
people to protest peacefully if they
want to to protest that is certainly
what the president's view would be so he
doesn't care if they're protesting
outside the supreme court or outside
someone's private residence
i don't have an official us government
position on where people protest i know
that there's an outrage right now i
guess about uh protests that have been
peaceful to date and we certainly
continue to encourage that outside of
judges homes and that's the president's
position i want to tell you kavanaugh
you have released the whirlwind and you
will pay the price
you won't know what hit you if you go
forward with these awful decisions
you've got to give schumer points for
follow through the democrats have in
fact unleashed a whirlwind against our
justices against their families against
the separation of powers and against our
entire system of government and you want
to hear the sickest part of it all
do you know what the pro-abortion crowd
did last night
just hours after the armed assassin was
arrested outside the judge's home
the pro-abortion crowd showed up again
for another illegal protest
they marched and they drummed and they
intimidated the justice again while his
children tried to eat their dinner and
go to sleep if at first they didn't
succeed these psychos showed that
they're just gonna try and try and try
again the fact that these leftists
showed up at kavanaugh's house again
just hours after the assassin was foiled
in his plot to kill the justice and
presumably his family too the the
assassin said he wanted it to be a
murder suicide but he's going to go in
there and shoot brett kavanaugh his wife
is right next to him in the bed you
don't think the wife is going to do
something you don't see a world in which
she ends up getting hurt too what about
his two daughters
so thankfully the assassin is foiled and
then the mob shows up again it's illegal
to protest outside of judges houses it
violates federal law and yet law
enforcement does nothing about it
they turn a blind eye to it
and and these leftist mobsters have
absolutely no shame they show up again
it reminds me of that scene in casino
speaking of mobsters
you know that scene in casino where joe
pesci is sitting there and he's talking
to the banker and he says if you don't
get me my money i'm going to go down to
that bank i'm going to break your effing
skull and then in about five 10 years
when i'm getting out of prison you might
be getting out of your coma and you know
what i'm gonna do i'm gonna crack your f
and skull again that's what i do i'm
stupid i don't care about you that's
what these leftists sound like they go
oh yeah we're gonna send an assassin to
your door and then oh and then you're
gonna foil the assassin because of the
two two u.s marshals that are sitting
outside and they're gonna arrest them
and and it's not gonna work and kavanagh
is gonna get to live another day well
you know what we're gonna do we're gonna
show up to your door again
that's what we're stupid that's our
business that's what we do
that is their business and they're going
to keep it up they're not going to stop
and they're going to be encouraged by
the people at the very heights of
government and you're going to see some
lip service
paid to how people shouldn't be violent
and no no they should don't do that
don't be naughty
but but maybe show up to their houses
even though it's illegal
and maybe maybe yell some threats just
to put a little pressure and maybe
unleash the whirlwind and maybe quote
maxine waters on all of the conservative
public figures get up in their face and
push back on them and say you're not
welcome here and go to their homes where
their children sleep but no we don't
want violence we don't want threats but
maybe show up outside their little
daughter's window and start screaming
and intimidating them but no but hey
look we wouldn't do that jen saki is
trying to weasel her way out of this
jinsaki was and this is uh you know not
not at the very moment of the attack
this is just after the the public
backlash against jen saki saying we
don't have a position on where these
unwhere these protesters show up no we
don't she's sitting there answering
questions from the audience and a
questioner says hey do you regret that
kind of language that puts the judges
into danger and she says what are you
talking about
a week ago after the roe v wade protests
were happening in front of the supreme
court justices houses you said and i
quote um we certainly can continue to
encourage that people protest outside of
judges homes i never said that
i'm quoting from i said peacefully yeah
sure peacefully that's a key word in
there he's fully regardless they're
protesting because they're trying to
impact the results
it's a federal crime to protest outside
of justice's homes to impact the results
so my question is do you regret
encouraging people to protest outside of
justice's homes even if it is peaceful
it still is a federal crime well first
thank you for your question and bring it
forward let me first say because i think
facts matter and facts are important i
never i never encouraged anyone to
protest i encourage them to do engage
peacefully and to do it without violence
without threats and without intimidation
and that's something i said many many
times and i think is vitally important
it is also true that peacefully
protesting in places where it is legal
and is legal in many places in the
country including outside of some places
in the country for sure is something
that is that is allowed every time she's
about to say something the thing she's
about to say she realizes is wrong or
illegal or dishonest and so she tries to
change it i never said that people
should protest the kid goes i'm
literally quoting from you yeah well but
i wanted it to be peaceful
sure that's actually irrelevant to my
question it's illegal to protest
violently or peacefully outside of a
judge's home to affect the results of a
case
well yeah but look i never told people
to protest i told them to well you
literally did i told them to engage
engage
peacefully and look that's legal it's
actually not legal it's explicitly
illegal in the u.s code well no but it's
legal outside of
place some certain places
and anyway and she's just moving the
goal posts
there's nowhere to move them to anywhere
she puts down the goalpost she is wrong
she encouraged people to do a thing
that's illegal to say nothing of immoral
and reckless so she's trying to walk it
back that that isn't going to work cnn
is trying to deflect so cnn realizes
gosh there's this assassin who showed up
yikes maybe our rhetoric was a was a
little hot okay well let's just say that
it's not the democrats it's not the
leftists it's both sides
very little detail at this point kate
other than to say it's
this man is he's an adult man from
california
we don't yet know what the nature of the
threat was we don't know what language
the threat was or what kind of weapon
this man might have had uh if he had one
at all because the information at this
point is just so thin but kate this
this
certainly contributes to this overall
threat landscape we've been talking a
lot about the major concern here with
this abortion ruling from federal
officials and they've been sounding the
alarm alarm on this for about a month is
that supreme court justices will
certainly be you know potentially
targeted by violent extremists who are
angered over this pending ruling that is
poised to strike down roe v wade this is
an extremely passionate issue there are
emotions on both sides federal officials
have made clear over and over they
believe the risk truly comes from both
sides of this abortion debate so
certainly this case uh you know really
solidifying what federal officials have
been warning about people are angry
yes the pro-abortion assassin
who showed up to brett kavanaugh's home
after he was encouraged to show up to
brett kavanaugh's home by some of the
most prominent democrats in the country
i think the lesson we need to draw is
it's really both sides
it's really
most importantly i think it's not just
one side it's definitely not us it's
both sides how on earth could it
possibly be both sides first of all
the political violence that we have seen
in recent years has been statistically
100 from the left the nearest thing that
they can point to as political violence
was that january 6 the worst of january
6 the worst day ever in history when a
horn hat guy danced around the capital
rotunda
and then they tried to lie about it and
say that the january six thurs
killed cops didn't happen it was
completely made up even the left had to
admit that it was made up
so they can't point to anything else
meanwhile we can point to blm blm killed
dozens of people burned down the country
for eight months at a time we can point
to this assassin here we can point to
that lunatic who almost killed steve
scalise at the congressional baseball
game he was a bernie bro we can go down
the list
at the political violence in this
country aimed at public officials it's
from the left but furthermore why would
the pro-lifers be upset
why would there be violence according to
the leaked opinion we're going to get
what we want we're going to get the
overruling of roe v wade so not only is
the is the violence not coming from both
sides
it is completely incoherent that it
would come from both sides it's coming
from the left and the libs who
encouraged this for months don't want to
claim any responsibility for it
the left has been drumming a specific
line for years now with increasing
volume and intensity and the line is
that the right poses a dangerous violent
insurrectionist terrorist threat to
america nicole wallace on msnbc had the
misfortune of of
promoting that line just slightly before
the leftist assassin showed up to
kavanaugh's house
if mr whitfield's mother was killed by
foreign terrorists the democrats and the
republicans on the committee would be
promising him the moon
what is i mean is it as obvious as it
seems that domestic violent extremists
are an important part of the voting
coalition on the right i mean what is
the structural impediment to pardoning
the homeland against domestic violent
extremism
really awkward timing here because five
seconds after nicole wallace says this
her own side gets caught trying to
murder a supreme court justice a
conservative supreme court justice but
the reason she's saying this is because
she's trying to make a big show out of
the january 6th hearings which nobody
cares about it's like fetch in mean
girls they keep trying to make it happen
it's not going to happen nobody cares
and the more information we learn about
january 6th the less serious it seems
the more farcical it seems
so
she's making this argument
for a reason not because it corresponds
to the facts but for a really basic
political reason
it's because if the left can paint the
right as as violent terrorist
insurrectionist extremists if they can
say that terrorists are an important
part of the coalition of the right then
they can more easily ostracize the right
deprive them of their basic rights us of
our basic rights kick us off of social
media
make it more difficult for us to
participate in the political process and
then they'll gain a little bit more
power
if you just look at the facts the whole
thing is absurd kamala harris raised
money to bail
violent domestic terrorists who actually
committed crimes during blm and were
arrested for it out of prison she posted
a link joe biden staffers did the same
thing maxine waters told her
constituents to push back getting the
faces of republicans in public
chuck schumer we're coming for you
kavanaugh you've unleashed the world
when the list go hillary clinton says
you can't be civil with your political
opponents the list goes on and on and on
and on and the left never acknowledges
that can you think of one example
of people on the right
suggesting anything even remotely close
to what the left has been calling for in
terms of
aggressive intimidating threatening
political engagement
no you can't you can't think of one
example the closest would be january 6
then what did donald trump say be
peaceful protest out in this public
space where it's legal to protest
outside in that public space peacefully
be peaceful so even that the best
example they've got is completely weak
it's all on the left but they do it
they do it so that they can ostracize us
i'm so glad you like that clip now
you've got to subscribe ring the bell
ding dong like whatever you got to do
make sure you get notifications for the
michael knowles show head on over to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts type in the michael knowles
show boom click link leave a five star
review we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you